well thank you for coming on the show
let's kick off Vladimir chivof you are
Russia's man in Europe and you're here
to talk to us today about the situation
in Ukraine but I want to kick off with
this can we really believe anything you
say and that the reason I ask you this
is that you toured the world's media not
long ago and an interview after
interview you assured the world that the
invasion of Ukraine wasn't going to
happen and I've got lots of examples
here's a couple this is CNBC on the 21st
of January
you said you were asked uh that
President Biden says you're going to
invade Ukraine you said there was no
evidence pointing to that that's not
your aim you are certainly not you said
and then another one the German
newspaper developed on February the 16th
this was a week before the invasion you
said as far as Russia is concerned I can
assure you there will be no attack this
Wednesday and you then went on to say no
escalation in the coming week either or
in the week after that or in the coming
months that was a week before the
invasion of Ukraine Ambassador did you
say those things because you were lying
or did you not know the truth you didn't
realize that the invasion was imminent
well uh as you quote I was referring to
the fact that uh a military operation in
the territory of Ukraine was not among
the aims of the Russian Federation at
that point
secondly on the 16th of
February
uh actually I believe I was speaking of
the 15th but never mind
I I was saying that
most well of the
recent Wars in Europe none was started
on a Wednesday and they proved correct
uh it nothing happened on the 16th and
nothing happened uh the following
Wednesday the 23rd
you said no escalation in the
consequence period
yes as far as the uh
the following period is concerned let me
uh give you a picture a broader picture
of events of that period
And I refer you to the 7th of February
if my memory doesn't fail me that was
the date
when President zielinski spoke
to the Munich security conference in
Munich yes the 7th of February and he
actually complained that Ukraine
now was lacking nuclear weapons and that
he was hoping that Ukraine will would
get nuclear weapons in the uh nearest
Future and the whole audience I will
remind you including leaders of many
Western countries uh warmly uploaded to
this blatant
expression of the desire
to violate the international treaty that
was that was February the 7th then on
February the 15th or 16th uh you said
there would be no escalation the coming
week either or in the week after that or
in the coming months that turned out not
to be true I just want to put that on
record there because it frames the
interview in that Russia repeatedly said
it wouldn't invade Ukraine when those
troops were massing on the borders and
that is not what happened uh that
Invasion did occur but let's move on to
where we are now sir
um
when we talk about the situation now the
U.S is director of the pentagon's
defense intelligence agency said this
week the Russians aren't winning the
ukrainians aren't winning we're at a bit
of a stalemate is that you're reading
too that there is a stalemate here and
how long do you think this conflict
could last well I must admit I am not a
military expert of course and I cannot
claim that I have the full picture on
the ground of what's happening but uh I
can assure you that the special military
operation that Russia launched on the
24th of February is proceeding according
to to the schedule
uh it uh it is not as quick as some
people would have wanted in Russia
uh it is continuing at a certain speed
uh
having in mind the various aspects of
the uh situation in Ukraine including
the need to protect the uh the troops of
the Russian troops and the
allies of the donuts can look on
People's Republic as well as the
civilian population had the Russian army
followed the pattern of the United
States and other Western countries we
would have steamrolled
Ukraine uh several times by now but that
was never the intention actually I
should repeat uh that it was not the
intention of the uh of Russia to capture
territory uh in Ukraine it is uh an
operation aimed at providing
uh security for uh for the donbass
people's republics as well as
demilitarizing and denitrification of of
Ukraine
to exclude the repetition
is to exclude the repetition of uh
aggressive uh attempts on the part of
the key of regime against donbassador
let's break that down a bit you said
it's not proceeding as fast as some
people would have wanted does that
include President Putin it's not quite
gone according to his plan
uh actually from what I know the
operation is uh proceeding in full
accordance to his plan uh otherwise you
will have to ask him okay well if you
give if you could please pass on a
request for an interview I'd appreciate
that
um just in terms of you said it's
proceeding according to schedule you
didn't Circle Kiev and then you withdrew
the troops to focus on the donbass
reason region lots of people would argue
that this Invasion has actually been a
story a failure that Russia has failed
to take Eve to take Carson to take leviv
or any other City even to take maripol
despite your best efforts you failed to
keep your Black Sea Fleet intact the
sinking of the muskva to divide the West
you failed on that you failed uh to
leverage yours dependence on your fuel
and to keep NATO at Bay I I would argue
or put it to you that if that's
proceeding according to schedule I
wouldn't like to see it when it goes
wrong for Russia
well I believe you shouldn't be jumping
to conclusions actually it was never the
intention of the Russian Armed Forces to
capture Kiev or Harker for any other big
city
uh the uh activity of the Armed Forces
was concentrated
if you didn't intend to capture it
so
actually the
actions undertaken at that initial stage
of the operation were focused on uh
destroying military installations uh
like uh uh anti-aircraft systems like
air airfields and Depots of ammunition
and armaments and that was successful
okay ambuster just in terms of other
parts of the plan our correspondent Alex
Rossi is in Ukraine he's been in
villages near kharkiv where Russian
forces have just recently left and has
found clear evidence of civilians being
killed in a trail of Devastation every
day we see reports of the same was that
in the plan as well to attack civilians
uh it was never the plan to attack
civilians and the and civilians were
never attacked
and the fact that uh a similar stories
are repeated on a regular basis uh
actually speaks of lack of imagination
on the organizers of those provocations
like in Buche and other places Mr
Ambassador just to be clear the the uh
the the evidence is being gathered by my
colleague uh it's not coming from the
ukrainians he is actually physically on
the ground uh in those Villages near
kharkiv
well uh I must admit uh that crazy
events are happening civilians are dying
but not at the hands of the Russian
Armed Forces
I'm I'm sure your colleague has not seen
Russian soldiers shooting at civilians
well there have been some reports today
of uh filming of Russian soldiers
shooting civilians but I I'd like to
come on to that later actually uh with
you what what I actually would like to
bring you to Mr Ambassador is you are
the man in Europe I want to talk to you
about Finland and Sweden EU countries uh
this week who have made moves to join
NATO what is your response to this
well I'm deeply disappointed
and saddened by those decisions
you know Finland
is not a very big country in terms of
population it's about 5 million or
something like that but it has uh
successfully been uh
pushing above its weight
uh uh having become in the last few
decades a major power in terms of
promoting Europeans security
architecture we all remember the
Helsinki Final Act of 1975
the
osc
which started as the CSC the conference
in Helsinki The Finnish capital and
actually
this punching above its weight was a
matter of
General respect for Finland and its
neutral policy
why
the current Finnish government has
chosen to uh to turn the country into a
Backwater
periphery of NATO
I cannot understand
so if Finland is a member of NATO
more or less likely sir no uh but uh as
my government has pointed out uh this
will necessitate certain military
technical measures
um like
improving or raising the uh the degree
of uh or defense preparations along the
Finnish border and the Russian Finnish
border is more than 1300 kilometers I
should remind you Mr Ambassador what
does that mean military technical
measures along the border what does that
mean troops along the border tanks along
the border what what I don't understand
what that is
not necessarily troops and tanks but
certain preparations uh definitely yes
like Radars perhaps but again I'm not a
military expert to to judge on those uh
technicalities Mr Ambassador have you
decided to come on uh the show and do an
interview tonight because you're here to
warn of the risk of this conflict
escalating into a wider European war is
that your message tonight
indeed and actually the issue that we
just referred to uh
NATO expansion in the uh shall I say
north northeastern
direction is another element to that
so you're saying that the expansion of
NATO into other European Union countries
and other European States could prompt
military retaliation from Russia is it
just words of warning what is it
well uh it will certainly necessitate
certain
um cons rethinking of the Russian
defense posture and uh what we are
particularly worried these days is of
course that uh while speaking about the
need for the Ukrainian conflict to come
to an end
uh Western leaders including leaders of
the European Union I should point out
are saying that the fate of this
conflict will be resolved on the
battlefield
so the European Union
but I think actually I find that in all
the interviews I've done we are
interrupting me all the time I I'm sorry
sir but
um I what I hear from Western leaders is
they would like a peaceful negotiated
settlement
then why are they uh pumping uh weapons
into Ukraine at an increasing speed that
will certainly not help unless they of
course want to fight this war until the
last uh living Ukrainian
and
Ambassador Mr let's just move on to
um sort of possible escalation in terms
of nuclear threat um can you explain
what President Putin meant when he said
this I have a direct quote from him this
is from April the 27th I'm sure you know
it he said if anyone decides to meddle
in ongoing events and create
unacceptable strategic threats for
Russia they must know our response will
be lightning quick we have all the
instruments for this ones nobody else
can boast of and we will use them if we
have to
is there a possibility of nuclear
escalation sir
well actually that quotation that you uh
just cited doesn't include the word
nuclear
uh but let me say that uh uh the Russian
military Doctrine
uh outlines very specifically the uh
situations when Russia may actually
proceed with the use of nuclear weapons
it's an open document you can read it
they start getting more or less likely
as time goes on
uh that depends on the others
can you reassure us that regardless of
what happens that nuclear weapons won't
be deployed in Ukraine that actually
this is about NATO and the threat from
NATO as you perceive it
you mean uh whether NATO will deploy
nuclear weapons in Ukraine I hope not
whether Russia would deploy nuclear
weapons in Ukraine
or on Ukraine why uh should Russia
deploy actually uh uh as distinctively
different from the United States Russia
does not deploy uh nuclear weapons
anywhere Beyond its own national
territory
let me bring you on to
um the issue of war crimes
um the international criminal court has
just announced an investigation on the
back of growing evidence will Russia
cooperate in that investigation
oh I don't think so because actually
neither Russia nor Ukraine are members
of that particular court which has a
very I would say depthful uh reputation
okay you don't recognize the
international criminal court do you
recognize the jurisdictions of other
International bodies such as the
international court of justice they
called on Russia to immediately suspend
military operations on March the 16th
the U.N Human Rights Council which has
formed an international Committee of
inquiry on UK Ukraine to investigate
Russian breaches of law the U.N human
rights monitoring Mission says it's
recorded instances of Russia using
cluster Munitions attacking hospitals
and the organization for security and
cooperation in Europe on April the 13th
they said the attack on maripole hostel
was a deliberate War crime do you
recognize any of those bodies or all
those organizations wrong
well let me let me uh start my reply
with a question uh from my uh part where
were all those uh International
institutions uh for the last eight years
when the Ukrainian Army and the
Nationalist battalions were waging uh a
terrible campaign against donbass when a
lot of people suffered more than 40 000
people died at the hands of the
Ukrainian Army not not a single of those
organizations has even said a word about
that well Ambassador
if it was a fake was it was a
provocation Ambassador I've just put the
point to you that if you participate
then the alleged war crimes you talk
about could also be investigated by
those International bodies but look
we're running out of time and I would
just like to ask you because I think
people would like to know do you think
that we can get to an eventual
negotiated outcome in Ukraine and what
might that look like from a Russian
perspective
well uh on a positive note I'm sure we
will come to a negotiated solution of
the Ukrainian crisis when that will
happen I will not try to to speculate
and how that
final solution will look like in detail
nobody knows but in principle
it will mean that Ukraine will be a
neutral State non-aligned
without any foreign military presence in
its territory that Ukraine will have
recognized the
donbass
republics and of course
the
reunification of Crimea with with the
Russian Federation and the rest will
will see in detail so our bus just to be
clear your vision of uh an independent
Ukraine would be uh the donbass would be
returned to Russia there would be a land
bridge to the Black Sea connecting
Crimea and uh Ukraine would not be
allowed to join NATO nor would it be
allowed to join the European Union are
they your terms for peace uh donbass uh
is actually consists of two uh primarily
two
independent countries that have been
recognized as such by the Russian
Federation
uh the donbass People's Republic and the
lugan's People's Republic
uh their territory uh will most probably
be the territory of the former donuts
can lugansk regions of Ukraine uh and uh
due to the fact that Russia has
recognized them and actually established
diplomatic relations with them they even
have opened up embassies in Moscow but
just finally how do you think it's going
to end do you think this will go on for
a number of years
well uh
if you allow me uh or a personal warning
to to the West before you burn all the
bridges with Russia think of the day
after that we will have to uh to rebuild
our relations on a new basis there will
be no return to business as usual uh the
world is changing before our eyes and uh
as soon as the collective West
uh to use the uh present-day phraseology
as soon as the collective West under
understands
uh that uh Russia is a country uh whose
interests should be reckoned with and
the current multipolar world which is
not limited to the west and Russia it's
a it's a big world besides uh uh Europe
North America and Russia uh and if you
look at the situation on a global scale
you will see that a lot of countries
they may not be very outspoken these
days but they share the global view of
my country
okay Mr Ambassador thank you very much
for your time
thank you